hey guys so we're in line for our covet
19 vaccines
back to nation 2021 shot number one
more and more people are lining up to
get their cobit 19 vaccines
half of all u.s adults have received at
least one shot
hey guys we're on our way to get the
second vaccine
pfizer so we'll keep you posted on our
side effects how we're feeling after as
they do many are now also sharing their
side effects
and some i had a tiny headache and a
tiny little red spot on my arm
are more common than others i don't know
if you guys can see it there's a little
bump
right above my left clavicle so what
side effects should people expect after
getting their shots
and when is it important to seek medical
attention
[Music]
i can't really lift my arm like past my
shoulder but that's it
side effects like this pain and redness
in the arm where a person received their
shot
are the most common dr kutika kupali
says
they can even be a good sign so the
reason for the symptoms is really
because your immune system
is revving up to develop those good
antibodies that you need
to help fight off the coronavirus if you
were to come into contact with it so
basically it's like a training for your
immune system
yeah that's a really good way to think
about it headaches
chills fever nausea body aches and in
some cases even vomiting or diarrhea
are normal if a bit unpleasant i have
been
running to the bathroom i feel like my
body's shutting down
people getting the two-dose vaccines
from pfizer and moderna may also feel
different from one dose to the next
many report feeling worse after the
second shot
second coved vaccine
the pfizer shot has me in the bed
the second time you get the vaccine your
body's already
experienced developing some of the
antibodies so your antibody
response and going to be much higher and
so that's why those symptoms you develop
are going to be a bit stronger but again
this isn't everyone doctors still don't
have enough data to say one dose carries
more severe side effects than the other
and whether the experience is different
for people who've had coving
i was getting a little bit concerned but
i figured this was just an enlarged
lymph node
so some of the less common side effects
that we've seen of the vaccine
have been what we call lymphadenopathy
or enlarged lymph nodes
though rare this swelling tends to
happen on the same
side of the body as the injection it's a
sign that your immune system isn't
working
and you know you might notice when you
get a cough or a cold you get
enlarged lymph nodes in your neck also
rare are cases where patients have
reported heart issues
temporary paralysis to one side of the
face or serious allergic reactions
resulting in rashes
and difficulty breathing this is one of
the reasons we have people
wait after they get their vaccine keep
an eye on you for 15 minutes okay
okay between now and then if you feel
anything outside ordinary please honk
your heart i want to come over take a
look and make sure you guys are okay
what's not normal is having a runny nose
cough or sore throat after getting the
vaccine
if you had those symptoms i would be
worried that you had some sort of upper
respiratory infection or possibly even
covid
so i would recommend getting tested
typically
any side effect starts to get better
within a day or two of getting
vaccinated
after that dr kapali recommends people
seek medical attention
also if they have things like difficulty
breathing shortness of breath
swelling things that would be considered
emergencies
one of the more worrisome adverse events
reported recently
is a very rare type of blood clot
several women experienced after getting
the johnson and johnson vaccine
more than 7 million people in the u.s
have gotten this vaccine
it really is one in a million people
that have
had this event for now u.s
regulators have paused distribution of j
and j's vaccine
though dr anthony fauci said he expects
the vaccine to return to use by the end
of the week
perhaps with additional restrictions or
warnings as was done in europe
what are some of the things that people
should do in order
to dampen their their side effects
i would try to schedule time to just
kind of
have a mellow day right so you don't
know how the vaccine is going to affect
you
but dr kupali says don't worry if you
feel fine
the vaccine is still working people over
55
typically experience fewer side effects
possibly because the immune system gets
weaker with age i don't want people to
think oh if i don't have a side effect
that's a bad thing
um you know people's bodies are
different as well
don't be afraid to get the vaccine
everyone reacts differently
me and my sister did not have any
symptoms that doesn't mean you won't but
in the end it's vitamin kopen